welcome to this video playing hail de
espinoza from Mexico Mexico yeah what do
we get Knight f6 keeps my options open
hmm yeah looks new mizzou Indian yep all
right you said hi going to say hi as
well yeah 93 93 okay I'm gonna for the
news oh it's really too good an opening
to not play I mean you cannot play here
defy for the Queens gambit which is
gaining popularity recently the
classical Queens gambit declined move
order Black has recently fared quite
well in them exchange variation and this
means that d5 is yeah kind of getting
back into fashion because only the
exchange was a problem there okay what
do we get here right now is some having
this big choice Bishop d3 92 yeah maybe
a three for an offbeat transposition to
the sameish Bishop d3 I have is the most
common move but 92 as some a move that
is recently yeah they all play that it
recently has been promoted and now quite
a number of books by am Shonda off
Watson I'm Russian I think he's Russian
Alex a corner for Grandmaster they all
promote Nagi too but it is a case where
they mostly go for their mouths because
of them
um yeah yeah good e-cigs I think what
you can still go d5 I can't play this
chord Isaac's they mostly go for that
because um they don't find any advantage
anywhere and 92 is at least a rather
early way to to cut some theoretical
work load it is really not giving any
advantage but this is some the case and
almost oh and let's say almost all our
limbs or lines okay so I kind of I
switched my setup here to add e65 being
set up right after he has committed to
90 g3 and Bishop to d3 i'm just playing
it like it was a like an old Indian or
so with c 6 and so on i might even play
g6 Bishop g7 it is a time loss of course
compared to a king's indian because i
have played Bishop before and back but
white has played a couple of moves in
the meantime like a 3 e 393 um yeah I
have the Georgian flag at the moment for
some people this is seven he brought
that to me yeah
I have to change that I don't know it
somehow happened that I got the Georgian
flag said I'm not quite sure how to set
that how do I said that
I guess NAB those I don't know yeah I
have to have to take a look there it's
kind of irritating I mean I don't have
anything against Georgia as a country or
so but it's kind of irritating for the
opponents that this flag is sir is there
so um how do i change that may be
somewhere here I don't find it simply
don't find it I have no idea okay I said
where i'll set the flex at the moment
here and dash i don't i don't know i
don't know i don't i don't even see it
don't see it at the mode so what am I
going to do here hmm yeah maybe I should
really prepare for the fianchetto my
position is rather flexible it's um it's
nothing brilliant but why doesn't really
have anything great to do
yeah this III d 4 is not very aggressive
you can play of course simple moves like
am Bishop b2 also but it's not quite
clear what is active planners I mean
difficult to change the pawn structure
be five maybe this is what what can do
b5 because after be five I don't really
want to take ever on Maya came maybe be
five I can maybe take d4 take you one
then see five or so it's rather
weakening he's taking he's taking a long
time so we just went for bishop they are
ok I'm going to play Bishop g7 not
taking a very long time
I have no idea why have the Georgian
flex it I don't I don't really know
don't find any any variable or anything
that I can said okay but what about this
game if he takes you 5 35 I can take
with both both just make some sense okay
it's just going back yeah I wonder I
wonder about all this should i take here
taking i come let's let's play in a
simple way pawn takes and then like d5
is definitely okay for black and denied
takes i go 95 and then possibly d5 yes
yeah why does not have enough influence
in the center here especially the night
on g3 is notoriously misplaced this is
actually what I don't like much about
the 92 light 9 the night is not so great
only tune will often move again and it
mostly goes two squares g3 at f/4 where
does not really do that much wow he's
taking a long time him right in the
opening
and 95 is a Russian Roulette pre-move on
94 you're fine on 85 84 you're not so
fine but again we're in great shape
timewise no need to be hectic mmm Jim I
think i would i would probably take with
the night but my rationale would be I
don't know made it takes I go D 5c 598
was my my thinking yeah my bishop 1c8 is
not getting into the game very quickly
now okay so maybe he takes hmm is there
any alternative and I think I should do
that that that is sound good or let's
say a decent strategic move I wonder if
he takes if I I can also can just play
94 maybe 94 is actually a move just
centralizing but I'm not sure oh that is
unexpected
okay i think i'm going to start with
Luke shakes the attack him is placing
the Queenie only one should be okay and
then take the night be six he has no
sacrifice or anything now that looks
quite fine gaining a temper with Knight
b6 i have d5 quite securely blocked and
a possible end game looks quite quite
promising actually yeah but should be
three years the only move that just I
mean this is the obvious move let's say
saying it's the only move that make some
senses may be a bit strong but I don't
really see him what else and then I was
thinking Queen d6 might be good gaining
a tempo on the night gaining a tempo on
the night and preparing Bishop to d7
Andrew key aide yeah I think that is
good I have no it's no no use to think
about Aegis about that it makes perfect
sense I don't think there's something
better or let's say much better 95 was a
possibility just blocking the whole
thing completely yeah not ft5 especially
would have been an idea his nights they
are they they are not doing that much
but what they do is I mean especially
here for of course controlling you sick
so I cannot so easily play Bishop b6
which would be really something that i
would like to do i would totally like to
trade LightSquared bishops to increase
my control
d 5 this is definitely the piece I want
to trade in general i like to trade here
horse that move i did not even think
about briefly ah huh interesting that's
kind of weird but it's not bad probably
hmm ok so I cannot take my queen is
attacked I cannot cover the Queen I mean
okay i can with Bishop f8 but this is a
really strange move and it allows maybe
maybe d5
hmm
ha I did not think about this at all I
mean I'm not sure if it is a problem but
I did not think about the move maybe
just back to the aid threatening a
discovery of the night or two fa it if i
go to f8 he might have Quincy 7 that's
not ideal quinte one would actually
repeat the position but okay I have a
ton of other moves than Queen d6 and
Queenie one looks completely ridiculous
of course okay I think rook to e1 is
some something that might happen
yeah rupee one looks perfectly logical
I'm threatening night ft 5 but at least
them some favorable trades and rookie
one is preventing that due to Queenie a
check or any other night move from xf64
that matter so lucky one looks
completely completely normal
I was thinking maybe night be 25 in that
case wow wow I did not even even vaguely
consider this one um okay
huh that looks really wrong it looks
like a like a strange wrong move and
maybe I go night to age five he has to
go to e3 yeah come on I'm going to play
that now not to think about this for
ages 95 Queenie for was still ok I
believe here Queenie for failing due to
Nigeria Bishop f5 dropping the rook on
b1 and when that happens yeah Queen III
was was necessary and then I ok but not
winning yeah this is winning the
exchange
ya know oh wait Bishop f7 no we can go
to HH everything else failed so Bishop
g4 here I guess just grabbing yeah let's
grab the pawn maybe you could have taken
on f7 again are we suffering offering a
queen trade that sir that's nice yeah
and I'm just going to play a five and
win the endgame very easily
yeah so I need I need the King points
here on a dark squares let's put that
here taking away some some squares for
the night and on dark squares you will
never be able to you do something with
this Bishop so that fields check very
solid check ya here we're going to trade
now nights I guess check ok so just
going to move the King over here and win
the King side so the easiest way to play
you cannot take c52 to see eight um okay
let's keep the bond for the moment
check
yeah they each phone will probably be
the pawn that promotes quite resigned
okay so it was a provisional game he did
not play that much of 15 15 minute yeah
let's do a quick recap of the skin we
had a think it's asking me for one more
game i really have to leave okay let's
let's have to let's have a look at the
game so this is kind of normal and
against nigeria black has more than one
possibility the simplest one and
probably best one is to go just d5 but i
like to mix the structure see a little
bit d6d six is definitely right against
Knight to f4 which is also line and this
will be a useful tempo yeah here so ki
Wendy six and e5 and well here I think
white is definitely okay castles when c6
before I think all this should be good
for a slight edge as mentioned i don't
think d6 in this particular in this
particular autumn g6 we should be too at
all it's all normal yeah and here i mean
don't know 92 is some a bit passive but
yeah i think around here should be ok
but i was thinking he really has to go
see five just to gain a little bit of
space and here i was thinking when
probably just night of 8 194 it's also
interesting this is be this is probably
about equal or maybe a slight edge for
white due to the space but not not much
yeah this is surprising the chest
it gives me the better structure now I
have the default pawn that I can attack
it is isolated and it's not not clear
what white has germs of activity yeah
this was a queen e 50 strong i did not
look I did not see the move at all which
means Queen d6 is probably not good I
should probably just play a normal move
here like night here with the other
night something like that yeah I really
I really have to go back it's kind of
awkward yeah now he surprised me by and
playing this strange movie but I think
rookie one looks very normal I mean just
taking some control over the e-file and
I know I probably play Bishop d7 or
something and then see what what happens
I was also thinking that this might be a
move like this and this butcher least
allows me to develop with Bishop e6 this
is probably about equal yeah rupee one
dough is a bit strange and now this is
just blundering it I was thinking he has
to go here and this is what what I would
have played which gives black the
slightly better game at least
yeah I don't know is it slightly better
a little bit more it is really a kind of
this is more than one problem the
problem is that this is weak this is a
passive bishop and it's not so clear
what this night is doing on the other
hand I'm not fully developed so well the
comp is giving me how a pawn which seems
fair yeah and after that it's just just
a whole exchange for not much I was
thinking that briefly thought he might
can might be a man take care of it like
a shy has just block it of course and
this is this is quite quite simple now
to to convert this extra exchange and
extra porn into a win yeah okay i hope
you enjoyed this game thanks for
watching